Simona we have just been hearing that
the those people gathered outside the US
Embassy have been ordered to withdraw
what more information do you have at
this point well that is correct
our contact on the ground who works for
the popular mobilization forces said
that the leadership issued an order for
those crowds to withdraw now it didn't
look like that when I was there just 30
minutes ago there were still supplies
arriving mattresses cooking utensils for
the crowds that had camped out overnight
as they laid siege to the US Embassy so
it looks like they were preparing to dig
in their heels and to stay for a long
time one of the people I spoke to told
me we will stay here until we feel that
the American government is respecting us
and giving us our rights and another
person said that we will actually stay
here until the American troops withdraw
from Iraq now of course the it depends
all on who is issuing the orders to
leave if it is the Iraqi government that
is asking them to leave those orders are
unlikely to be heeded if it is senior
leadership of the popular mobilization
forces because maybe some kind of deal
has been struck between the PMF and the
government then we're likely to see the
gradual departure of those crowds and
and smaller what does this whole episode
say about who is in charge at the moment
who has the upper hands when it comes to
Iraq well it's pretty clear from the
events yesterday and also today that it
was the popular mobilization forces and
their leadership who were calling the
shots what is difficult to say is how
much support these events had from the
Iraqi government of course in the public
domain we heard statements from prime
minister Adel Abdel Nasser condemning
the attack on the US Embassy in asking
for those crowds to leave but it's
difficult to say whether that is the
actual stance of the government or
whether this is just an official
statement to a peace for example the
United States presence here or whether
this is actually something that the
government
really believes in because from what we
saw on the ground was in rocky security
forces standing down letting these
crowds of members and supporters of
popular mobilization forces pass right
through the checkpoints enter the
fortified Green Zone and attack the US
Embassy but any intervention whatsoever
now even today we could see an increased
presence of Iraqi security forces but
they were still not taking any action to
really remove those crowds they were
just standing by they were monitoring
the situation but they had not been
given any orders to really put an end to
that siege so all of this suggests that
it was the popular mobilization forces
who were really in charge and who were
essentially setting the stage here and
basically no telling the government you
know what what will happen with these
crowds and it is pretty clear that the
Iraqi government either does not have
the capability to resist or does not
have the political will to do so
okay so Mona 14 for now thank you very
much indeed for bringing us those latest
developments coming out of Baghdad